okay
let's see for people joining this live
stream we are continuing our discussion
of uh data set and the presentation of
data set
so let's see how hold on a second
i am not seeing the usual stream that i
see
let me go ahead and reset
something here um
see if i can get this to work
okay i have it okay
great so things themes can affect
so is this based on our previous is this
based on my notes from last time or what
yes
this notebook is essentially those notes
cleaned up and organized
okay okay we left off last time with
brett's
uh comments about number formatting
which are at the bottom of the proposed
themes
at the very bottom um
no no that's a different issue that's
that's addressing the very bottom of
what
um let's see it would be uh liquid
okay so first of all i should i should
save this in the appropriate place
um
where was that just just search for
scientific it'll find it
i could not apparently not keep going
um there you go okay
okay all right so
this is something that i mean like
number precision scientific notation
um you know having a good
way to set that in general you know we
have number form but essentially what
we're asking for here
is the you know
is the options of number form as in
number formatting arrow
and i think there's an argument that we
should imagine that style
could do that in other words that we
could imagine doing something where we
say
style i mean i'm just talking about in
general style of expert comma number
formatting
arrow blah blah blah
what does a number format do
oh i see that's okay
all right that's not that inconsistent
with this am i making sense people
understand what i'm saying or not
yeah yeah i mean presumably there's
existing options that
would
yeah i mean that's the and then if we
had a number formatting option for style
which could be used in lots and lots of
places then we could put number
formatting
as an option in graphics in all kinds of
places
right so that then it would affect
things like tick labels and so on am i
making sense
yeah yep so i think this is the wrong
group to examine that
but perhaps you can uh
you can chase that okay who um let's see
probably
jose in the ild group is probably the
right one to consider that
okay okay do you understand yeah
oh jose is here great what do you think
about this
yes this could be considered together
with a
number for uh number form options
right i mean that what i'm thinking is
that this is a useful thing in general
because right now
if you okay here's the issue with number
form
you get to wrap a specific expression if
you want
number formatting to seep into the
corners of something like a data set or
a graphics there's no way to do that
right how do you specify the the style
of tick labels well there's a text style
option right
but that's a big nuisance uh making
sense brett do you understand what i'm
saying
yes i understand okay
and i agree okay fine
so similarly i could imagine a style
you know i could even imagine a style
for
um you know a date formatting style
i'm not sure
you know because that's again something
that we have um
um right a general way to do that
is this making sense okay there is an
opportunity
itself okay but so maybe this is a way
to
date formatting is a way to give
to do that to seep into other functions
i'm not sure but anyway i think this is
what we you know that's the general kind
of approach that we want to make here
i don't think now so the one thing we
might want to do
is have an attached cell for the data
set
that has settings like switch on and off
scientific notation those kinds of
things
right so a ui element in addition to
programmatic
kinds of things yes do you understand
uh yeah i mean that could be an
extensive thing
if you want to i know it should be i
mean eventually we will we should have
an attached cell for data sets and and i
think
noah has a framework now if i understand
correctly for attached cells
and a way of thinking about them for a
bunch of different kinds of of objects
i mean he's primarily working on drawing
tools right now nowhere is that a first
statement i mean would you know what to
do roughly
to make an attached cell for a data set
um yeah structurally i think so
okay there's the issue of what how how
do you indicate what your what part of
the data set you you're
uh want to affect well make a selection
on a data set
i think this is a whole data set
attached cell
there are plenty of things that are
whole data set type stories
um but i mean most of these options here
well okay here's what we could do okay
in a ui hack in a sense
is like it's you know
uh indicate the selection by effigy so
to speak
as in you have you know if you need to
you can have a thing which shows you
know in the attached cell
you can get sort of a a version of the
data set
that you indicate so that you can
indicate like a particular column or
something
like this
um by the way i do want to make sure
that we come back in a subsequent ild
meeting
to talk about tally's suggestion about
um named levels in objects
which i think would first get used in
dataset
am i making sense
did you understand what i'm saying or
not yeah is this like
slice
i don't know what it's like i don't know
what slices
so i mean what this is is right now
if we have something like this right
we get to name you know the levels here
are just one two three
right but we could name the elements
with an association
but we don't have a way to name the
levels
did you understand what i'm saying
so this is like using raw column and
further words
i i suppose so i mean i suppose what we
want to be able to do
is to be able to say somehow here
um
you know this is something like a um
uh and not a good name but a labeled
array
in which it's not a good name
but and you know the question is how do
we put
you know this is would be a pretty
general construct
that would have to be supported in lots
of places but the whole point of it
is that that way instead of referring i
mean this is relevant
for our hierarchical array structures
do you see what i'm saying i mean right
now we can name a column but we can't
name
the the level that has columns on it
do you see what i'm saying not entirely
okay let me go through it again okay the
planet data set you're
you know wanting to let you know have
moons as a label or something
yes but but right let me explain this
everybody here showing us
understand this this here i can get a
part here
like i can say part one comma two comma
one
okay oops doesn't exist one comma one
comma two whatever it is
right and the length of that part
specification
is a level right so here i can say
what i must be using some prototype
build here
um oh gosh
okay um i can say what is on level
two for example
right so this is like using names
in the level spec argument so instead of
saying
map at two you could say
map at columns
yes exactly exactly
hans on our live stream is asking what
happens if two levels have the same
uh name i think it's like associations
you can't do that
probably i don't know i mean there's
quite a bit of semantics to work out
here
anyway it's not really the subject of
our current meeting but we should we
should
address that in a subsequent meeting
okay
uh please guide this this meeting chris
what should we talk about next um
well if you go to the plot themes
documentation there are a couple of
things that we haven't explicitly
mentioned
okay
so if you scroll down we'll open the
details and then scroll down a little
bit
okay so there are these feature themes
and color feature themes applied to the
data set
you might want to have different themes
for we discussed that
for backgrounds well it's not on our
list well we discussed that
and then the font feature themes uh
similarly
right for large sans-serif so forth
yep i think we discussed this i mean the
i mean
we mentioned fonts and colors so what we
need here
is okay
so look somewhere here um
these are names there's the question
okay there's a couple of questions this
first is
the actual settings for things like i
want to set
the you know the borders to be green
right so we've got a bunch of settings
and then we've got a bunch of these
things
that we could do with settings but
they're just a big nuisance so we want
to do
with themes right there are also things
we can't do with settings
am i making sense
do you understand what i'm saying well
there will be some
some some effectively internal options
that aren't
accessible other than by themes well
perhaps
yes perhaps i don't know what they are
but like for example if i want to change
everything to scientific notation
how would i do that
uh you currently you do it with an item
display function
okay fine so there are things which can
be set so
it is is it your belief that every
aspect of the
of the of the presentation can be
determined by some by a setting perhaps
a function
um that is a setting for some existing
option is that true or is that not true
that's not true there are some things
that are not yet supported like like
the styles of the frames of spacing
okay but so are those things in fact
accessible through internal options or
not
no and the frame the frame
thing is a big can of worms in data set
which i haven't attacked
it's not it's not at all straightforward
okay
um is there a good reason why i'm
running the prototype build here i guess
that there is because you've got new
features in dataset and prototype build
correct
you don't you don't need the prototype
build
and i think i'm going to not use it
because i think it's going to lead to
more trouble
um so there's nothing in prototype
am i sure using the 12-2 head branch
build or should i be using yeah
okay
okay so i want to make sure we
understand what the objectives are
in this meeting what are they
to define the set of themes that
design will go away and design
okay all right so i think tim is leading
that effort so he should say what he
doesn't know yet
what he needs to know from this meeting
am i making sense
okay if everybody knows what to do then
we should not have this meeting
does everybody know what to do or not
if they don't know what to do they
should ask questions here so that we can
determine
what we should be doing this is so
obvious i was
i thought that design was coming up with
the actual themes
is there anybody from design in this
meeting i i'm here i thought the
opposite
they would be based on the ones we see
here right so the core set
is the standards that we have business
web right and then in addition we need
to agree to the others but this is the
basis set
plus dark mode that we talked about yep
so so
translating these to data set seems like
it fits
tim unless i'm wrong here and i could
assign somebody
i could it's probably better if tim does
it but
but so maybe there's other creative
themes that we could kind of help with
but
we'll have to define those so so i have
a couple of thoughts since
the meeting the other day um and i think
mostly these are questions for chris
at least initially so
chris my understanding is that the
you know whether something gets
displayed as rows or columns
it sort of depends on
what the thing is and where it is and
it's not necessarily just
alternating between rows and columns
that's right
yeah yeah so there's extra issues which
is the overall layout right yeah so i
was
thinking about that force rows okay
rows columns or or wrapping
so so i have an agenda an item on my
agenda for an option that lets you
expose where is that on this agenda
it's not in here it's not related to
themes explicitly
but there's a plan for a layout option
that lets you specify explicitly what
you want things to be
okay so what would that look like it
would say data set layout
arrow and it would essentially be like
row comma column comma column comma row
or whatever
is that really the words we want to use
i mean well probably strings
okay suppose it could also be horizontal
and vertical
yeah that's possible that makes more
sense to me but there's also wrapping
oh so you you mean like the data set
range of 100 where it
you know shows it as a 5 by 20 thing or
whatever
yes exactly
i mean that's the there's that case
there's the
i mean so this would be a level based
and if we have named levels at some
point that will become an association
data set orientations
or something it's not quite i mean we
shouldn't call it layout that's too
general a name
um
data set arrangement
something orientation it's not quite
orientations because of the automatic
case
and i could imagine is there a an analog
of that case
see there's a that case in general
you could imagine something that says i
want to do
um n column wrapping
okay so this is did you see what i'm
saying so the the
vertical is one column wrapping right so
given
what we're looking at there is given
if i say array um
i mean this is what we're talking about
here this is
three comma one matrix form let's say
that's wrapping like that
right but i could take assume those are
just successive numbers
right i could also take this case here
right where i'm taking my sequence
and wrapping it in pairs like that yeah
that's the generalization and similarly
in in
um in rows i could have something i
could easily have
a row
you know wrapped columns you know
wrapped rows also makes sense like
in other words let's say i have a
hundred a hundred columns
right eg a hundred columns
and i want to show
you know and i want to wrap those
columns
i'm sorry i just realized that we have a
table directions
option ah look at that that is that is a
relevant option
why is this raft oh god this bug is
still not fixed
devin could you make sure that they're
aware of the fact that that bug is still
not fixed
supposed to be fixed like two weeks ago
kind of annoying that's a tom sherlock
bug
he should have fixed it
okay yes this is highly relevant
right this is highly relevant i mean i'm
not sure i'm that keen on this is
probably a version one option
no version two i'm off by a couple of
years
um
i mean arguably we should be slowly
merging the table form
formatting with data set formatting
chris what have you done along those
lines
well be nothing explicitly
okay well you should be thinking about
it
have you even looked at what table form
does
um not recently okay so that's something
else for the list
okay so this is clearly another
another thing whoops this is this should
say data set arrangement
but whether that's you know right so
this is
this is using row column well we'll
clearly have to merge those ideas
so what's the relationship of this to
themes are you anticipating themes
that lay things out as all rows or raw
columns
i would think so yeah that was what i
was thinking
you know like even if you have multiple
levels that you just have like a
hierarchy of
labels on the left side let me give an
example of a theme issue
okay so theme is something like
um uh um
rap for page ie
don't let that's that
it's not the right name i.e don't let
rose
get wider get wider you know don't let
the rows get wider than the page
you know wrap them do you see what i'm
saying or alternatively
it could be a lied you know a lied for
page or something
i don't know what the right you know
yeah something like that
that those are those are a couple of
issues now
you know in terms of vertical height
we've got the max items option
i think that there's a theme there that
says
horizontal what's that that's vertical
and horizontal
okay okay fine and what does it do when
you hit max items
horizontally it'll either
um well it'll usually allied or it'll
give you let's take a look at that
do we have a good example um yeah you
can you can just use the
planets data set or
yeah the planets they just said
what's it called is it called planets
yeah planets yeah wrap that with data
set
it is a data set yeah but you want to
add an option now
okay
and then give it max item zero four
comma two
so you get scroll bars in each direction
okay if the max items is explained to me
why that's vertical scroll that
horizontal scroll bar is not full width
because the data set doesn't actually
know the sizes of its contents
so i did actually implement that once
it's very expensive to compute
and it just it just blogs it down
completely it's we can't do it
so it just use it knows the minimum
column width and it bases it on that
okay so one of the issues here and this
is something for
i'm asking kind of noah uh christina
tim etc i mean the fact that we've got
you know we got seven different kinds of
arrows here
with different styles and things like
this and we've also got
and also okay so
cool
so if i hit this thumb right
if i hit that thumb and i re-hit it i'm
i'm out of place
right why do you extend the
that uh horizontal scroll bar because if
i didn't you'd ask me why isn't the
scroll bar resizing
you know what is the size it's half the
height i mean you don't know the width
so
just it just bases it on i mean do the
same thing vertically you'll
you'll see a better example of why it
resizes
go to the scroll all right and
right now i i i'm guessing you want that
scroll bar to
reset okay so this is like a window
resize what does a window do
i see so a window the difference is
that a window doesn't have
multi-scrolling
a window doesn't resize itself based on
uh clicking a button right so we don't
have the same issue with the window with
a window
all bets are off and the scroll bar is
moved if
if scrolling were not row-wise then you
could
you could do that you could have a fixed
size
these are not very responsive either
i mean that was that was that's very
unresponsive i mean if i
if i and also i don't believe in this
thing where you're changing the the
mouse
mouse because uh when
yes we we noted that last week oh wait a
second so this
this scroller
what is that state oh wow okay so this
scroller
as it comes down
is extending is that really the right
thing to have a thing that looks like a
scroller
that does that extension i mean it'd be
one thing if i
see a window i would have expected this
scroller would show me this window
scrolled down not that that expands the
thing i would have expected a different
thing to expand it
so what that's what this is doing is
scrolling by top level rows
oh i see some of those are different
heights
oh so the issue with having smooth
scrolling
is that you want to you want to format
this only the section of the data set
you're looking at
in order to have smith if we're doing
this it seems to me we should have
little fiducial marks in the skull bar
so that you're not as surprised about
the fact that it's doing this
what do you mean by solution marks well
i mean some ticks that show
what corresponds to because because in
this state
right in that state there
this is showing is this showing what
fraction
this is showing a certain fraction of
the data set right [ __ ] there are four
rows here right
four eight yeah right and so down here
there are we could imagine putting ching
ching four little dots there
ching ching four little dots there
so at least when it when it expands
you're not as confused i mean what's
incredibly confusing is
in this state here the dots
up here are very much spaced apart
right and the dots down here well the
you know the dots are presumably equally
spaced
within this skull bar am i making sense
yeah dots are always equally spaced
within the scroll bar
but the scroll bar changes size this is
really weird
and i also i just don't get why
this arrow is a different style of arrow
from this one here
that's what i inherited those decisions
were made before i came to this project
but that was before there were scroll
bars
no there were scroll bars there were
there's always been a vertical scroll
bar okay well i i don't think it's right
i mean jeremy do you want to comment on
this just looks ugly to me
i mean i don't see why it doesn't look
nice um
i don't remember the decisions on those
aerotypes that was years ago with tally
i think that what we should do i think
we should try to
take this kind of arrow and put it here
as well i mean if this is doing the same
thing
is it doing the same thing i think it is
doing the same thing
right yeah making sense
if it if it's doing the same thing so
probably just the arrows on the bottom
should be enough
yeah there's a number of issues here
sure
well we should probably yeah we can
interact with it and to reveal more
details
and propose some updates so yeah
i mean look the problem is
yes i think those arrows
you know we believe it's useful to have
a scroll bar
because the scorebar is basically giving
you the same information as this
right
but we think it's useful to have a
scorebar although the truth is the
scorebar is kind of
clunky in its operation and it's slow
it's a question from brian on our live
stream asking can we resize the data set
with a a a um whatever those things are
called
the little thing with the besides the
ridges on it what's that
a resize thumb yeah yeah we
you suggested that i mean that would
clearly be a useful thing to be able to
do and that would arguably be
look there's two actions there's
resizing
this is very confused there's two
different actions
one is resizing okay
one question is are you seeing
essentially a window here
or are you seeing a fixed number of rows
here and you've made the decision that
it's a fixed number of rows
rather than a window on it
that was made before i started on this
well maybe it was made for reasons that
we don't now
know and they may not even be sensible
well one reason is you only want to
format the part of the data set you're
looking at you don't want to have to
format the entire database but that's a
that's a implementation detail i mean
yes
but i presume that's one of the reasons
that that decision was made
okay but fine but we can clearly solve
that problem by estimating what part of
the data set we have to format
and you know trying to get and seeing
then as we paint it
do we need to format more it's kind of a
tiled approach to formatting
right
okay so we have a problem here but um
also what is probably missing is
actually numbering of rows
because then the scrolling it was hard
to figure out what's going on with the
scrolling because there is no numbering
of rows
and we don't want a number rows we don't
want a number of rows it's ugly to
number rows but i agree that having
row numbering if we're going to label
the rows with numbers down here
yeah there's a certain argument that
that on hover for example that they
should get numbers
i mean the truth is a data set
you know should look beautiful but if
you're going to interact with it
it can start having all kinds of marks
on top of it because by the time
you're mousing into it we know you want
to interact with it
and so better to have you know it's okay
if it has all kinds of
of construction markings in it
i was gonna say having the numbers
available is useful for them doing
part extraction it is things
it is but i mean on hover doing that on
hover seems to me a sensible thing
and you know
look what's good about the scroll bar
except it isn't good in this case
is you know some visual indication of
what part of the data you're looking at
and it's also probably more convenient
to go
through and scroll down in the data here
than to use those buttons but in any
case okay so this is the thing we need
to look at from a
ux point of view um sounds good yeah
we'll look into that any particular
comments noah do you have any particular
comments on this
um i can't think of anything useful
it is awkward that the scroll bar sort
of changes size it's very
um sort of distracting it was just
confusing like once you scroll down i
think once you've done it a few times
you get used to it but um
yeah i'm not sure how to solve that to
be honest right now
okay and is it really not possible to
have it scroll
by the inner rows instead of the outer
rows
well that's a windowed approach as
opposed to a an integer number of outer
rows
but that doesn't really i mean it
doesn't really solve the
problem it just makes a little finer
grain well also but
down here if we're saying displaying
rows blah blah blah blah blah
right that's still going to have the
problem if you press one of the down
arrows there
it's still going to then expand it to
show you know macro rows
right right
it also messes up whatever markers you
want to put in the scroll bar or potato
just makes it more complicated i guess
you mean in terms of what you put the
outermost rows as markers in the scroll
bar i guess you sort of
assume when you move the scroll bars to
those
but it won't yeah right and you could be
sort of halfway through
markers which might be a bit confusing
that would be super confusing
right okay okay so there are some issues
here
all right but we're mostly talking about
themes so this kind of thing
about how you wrap it i mean in other
words the choice of max items
seems like you know fit on
page you know wrap for page width or
something
or actually it doesn't necessarily wrap
for pages it will be something like
um um fit
page width or
you know infinite width
right those are the two cases that seem
to me sort of obvious cases
am i making sense do you understand what
i'm saying chris
yeah yeah i mean does that seem right to
you
that those are the two cases you either
want it so that you're going to have a
scroll bar
because it's too wide for the page then
put a scroll bar
or well no that's not actually fit page
width i mean
uh you know there's another one which is
scroll up page width
right or infinite width right
so fit page width or a light to page
width
that's otherwise would be lied to page
width
something is wrong with the selection
please report that
i've reported that
i mean these aren't the right names but
that's what it means they lied to page
width scroll up page width
um infinite width
right a light page height
am i making sense yeah
so it was infinite width that it would
just you'd rely on the notebook scroll
bar too
oh that's an interesting question that's
an interesting question yeah
okay so that's an interesting question i
mean scroll up page width
yes i think that's what that would mean
yes which makes some sense to me
right okay so we have to understand how
to map
so these are these are important things
um you know to me
yeah brian is pointing out it needs a
way to specify an absolute i mean does
it have an image size
no what's that no it doesn't okay well
it probably should
it depends what image size means and
what it i mean
just like we have in pain for example
we have a bunch of ways to select what
happens
right
this is how does action
what's it called image size action okay
all right because that's again i mean to
me that's that that is a sensible thing
right and there's also the question of
how does the data set
format like if if i output this to pdf
what does it do
it needs to look beautiful
have we worked on that what does this do
if i if i
export it to pdf i don't know
okay i'm rolling my eyes here i thought
we were actually
you know okay i mean there's lots of
ways you can export it i haven't
i haven't done anything that's a matter
of the you know okay so
okay so there's a question yes i
understand but it's it's also
i mean it's a question of exporting
to pdf
uh html is it gonna make an html table
what's it gonna do
i mean that's also relevant i mean
obviously in the cloud we know what it
does
right it has it has its actual you know
the functionality works in the cloud
doesn't it
export no chris data sets
yes of course yeah okay all right so all
the
features that you're adding will also
work in the cloud
yes okay
but so all right
so again okay we we we're running out of
time here
um oh shoot i have to go um
right so this is the issue of color
function scaling which is a much bigger
issue and data set well that's an issue
for basically that's an appearance
option
that's the okay item display function
right that's what you're talking about
is the item display function not only
any any so any option can have a value
which is a function
so this really applies to just about
every every option and data set
right okay but but but the basic
question is
does it get fed the raw data right or
does it get fed okay so
basically what we're looking at there is
what to feed the functions yep
right and so the way we've done that
elsewhere
is we've said i mean i think the right
way to do that probably okay so there's
a couple of approaches
one is to have an association with
scaled versus whatever
another is to have something analogous
to our handler functions
and say something like
oh boy yeah i mean so that's gonna have
to say
because that's a global item display
function
um and you might want different things i
mean the issue is
how do you get environmental information
eg you know scale relative to every
value in the data set
versus um versus scale relative to this
row
right
etc
um
okay so that's the question is how do we
get and we haven't really had this issue
before
because we have had color function
scaling
is what is it how does it scale it's fed
well there's only lots of tools yeah i
mean there's only one set of uh
there's only one data set to scale
relatively to so that that issue is not
actually because it's a single level
object yeah
well it's viewed as a single level
object i mean an array plot for example
we're viewed as everything is in the
same kind of bucket
all the elements of the array are in the
same bucket right
so you know now that i think about one
slot two et cetera for different
you know like plot
thing right but that isn't a color
function scaling issue that's not what
that's doing right
mesh functions you can do different uh
levels right
well i mean so like plot 3d the color
function can take three arguments
x y and z and color function scaling
takes a list of
you know trues and falses really
in in the general form i didn't know
that
okay
well that's a model for this right
because that
yeah i i've outlined so now that i think
about option one that i
presented here is not going to work so
option two is really the only option
and i have i have the outlines of how
this option should work it gets a little
bit messy but i think at the top level
which most people will use is pretty
intuitive
i can flesh that out and we can talk
about it
uh at another meeting okay
all right okay okay but i didn't know
that the color function scaling
well the scale argument i of the color
function
interesting okay
so that we're going to have to do
something like that yep and here
this is very very weird this is saying
whether to scale
the things for that yes but i think it's
necessary
otherwise you're limited to either
scaling for everything or not scaling
for everything well the other
possibility would be to have an
association
be the thing that is fed to the item
display function
that includes both scaled and unscaled
cases
well but then how do you tell it what
just what to scale relative to
yeah i understand that's an issue i mean
i don't know how many choices there are
whether you know it's basically scale
relative to this level
well essentially it can be any any path
in the data set can specify
a scaling set
it could but i think we can as well yeah
i mean i think by that level of
non-uniformity i think you should put
different data in your data set
i think you only bank switch it go ahead
yes yeah i mean specifying those
option names is messy but i think it's a
really rare case
people don't probably don't even need to
be aware of that but it can be available
in case they need it
in the usual case you would just specify
a path and true or false
i have to run unfortunately see you guys
sorry i'll flesh that out
right all right thanks thanks guys here
thanks guy
people do we know who's going to work on
this now
from okay i'll let you guys talk about
this i've got to go